so this is a really beautiful sample of
chromium two chromium's a transition
metal right in the middle of the
transition metal series there and it's
used to protect metal components and you
very often you see chromium plated
components on cars perhaps some of the
older cars you know the the wheel trims
or perhaps the grilles on the front but
if you look at the sample it's really
lustrous really beautiful and shiny so
there's some elements that one's really
front fond of and chromium is one of the
ones that I really like it's a metal you
will have seen it in many places it's
used for plating materials this may
actually be stainless steel but chromium
looks very similar and it was very
popular for plating bumpers all sorts of
materials in the 1930s up to the 1950s
so you can get dull chromium as well
which is where the surface is very bumpy
and the light tense would be absorbed a
lot more are not reflected my interest
in chromium is that in the chemistry one
of the very first bits of chemistry
research I did it's school was involving
copper chromate I spent months doing
experiments on it I didn't really
discover anything about it but it was
great fun one stage I had a whole row of
test tubes of copper chromates
above my bed and my bedroom at home and
more recently that I've done when I
started doing doctorates I did
experiments with chromium making new
complexes of chromium and one of the
very first compounds that my research
group ever made that was new that nobody
else had made before was a compound of
ethene and chromium chromium Penta
carbonyl ethene so I have very warm
feelings about it